nearly ten months ago president-elect
Trump tapped then va undersecretary
David Shulkin to lead the nation's
second largest federal agency behind the
Pentagon the Obama administration
appointee had already started packing up
his office
we spoke with Secretary Shokan at a VA
hospital in New York and he opened up
about his successes his challenges in
his unique relationship with his boss
the president you are the only holdover
from the Obama administration were you
surprised when President Trump picked
you I guess I'd have to say yes but when
I look back upon it it makes sense the
president is aligned with where Congress
is where I am which is that our veterans
deserve better and we just have to make
the decisions to fix the system I
appointed today the head secretary of
the Veterans Administration David
Shulkin David Shulkin wasn't a big name
before he took the helm of the country's
largest healthcare system but as
Secretary of Veterans Affairs his name
does get frequently mentioned secretary
Shulkin is here you have done an
incredible job
he's worked quickly to change the VA
getting bipartisan laws passed to boost
accountability and fulfilling a campaign
promise for his boss it will be properly
implemented right David better be David
are you his favorite cabinet secretary
no I don't I wouldn't say that I think
you know the president certainly feels
passionate about veterans and I think
that he's proud of the progress that
we're making
but you were the Undersecretary of
health at the VA when Trump was running
for president and he called the VA a
broken system a disaster what changed
his perspective of the VA you know I
don't disagree with the president this
is a system that has lots of problems
and you have to recognize and
acknowledge the problems if you're going
to fix them for years the VA has
struggled to modernize and to overcome
fallout for a massive weightless scandal
in which dozens of veterans died waiting
for care after everything that's
happened and after Congress approving
ten billion dollars so the veterans can
go outside the system to get care why is
the number of veterans waiting more than
30 days bigger than it was three years
ago
first of all we've increased the number
of appointments by several million
appointments since 2014 so what you're
seeing is a system that's experiencing
tremendous demand for services this is
because of all the veterans coming back
from Iraq and Afghanistan one of the
things most Americans don't understand
is is that when you send men and women
off to war it sometimes takes decades
before you see the impact of that demand
that 10 billion dollar choice program is
set to expire what do you need now we
need Congress to work to make sure that
the Choice Program is a permanent part
of a program that supports veterans
going on in the future otherwise we risk
running out of money and putting
veterans back into the type of waitlist
situation that we saw many years ago
guys getting good care it's a scenario
Shulkin seems determined to avoid a
trained physician he continues to see
patients at the VA hoping to restore
them and their system to good health
there been reports that you've been
interviewed for the Health and Human
Secretary's job would you take that job
first of all those reports aren't true
I've not been interviewed I am committed
to starting finishing the job that I
started that's where I want to be of
course I serve at the pleasure the
president and I would ask you to serve
as HHS secretary you know I think
anybody who serves the president is
there to serve the country and of course
we would do what the president wants us
to do but the president knows he and I
have discussed that I feel committed to
the Veterans Administration and that I
feel that we're making great progress
and I don't want to interrupt that one
question why have they made the point
you pointed out in terms of the delay
has gotten worse why is it getting worse
well because we have more veterans in
the system is one reason also he says
he's made it instead of different types
of ways that you can sign up there's
just urging care and
on urgent care so there's different
lines that you go into there's still a
lot of concern that there are veterans
who cannot get the care they need
immediately complaints that people are
dying waiting for care but he is making
big changes and I think President Trump
is sort of unleashed him there is a lot
still coming ahead I think that we'll
see the VA they are not planning to
privatize the VA that is one of the
biggest concerns by veterans but this is
a big change that's coming in he really
is he's and he's like seemingly on both
sides of the aisle that has to be a very
good thing - he is the only cabinet
secretary who was unanimously approved
and we wanted to do this because
Veterans Day is coming up course of
course and health care is important very
nice to meet him that way thank you know